quand ils naissent ici ils sont bien
plus à risque d'être enlevés à leurs
parents car au pays plus de la moitié
des enfants placés en familles d'accueil
sont autochtones même s'il représente
moins de 10% de la population
c'est ce qu'a vécu acheter bat crise dès
sa naissance par les services sociaux
elle a grandi en colombie-britannique
loin de sa communauté du nord de
l'ontario
moi je n'ai pas vraiment de maisons dit
m
pour compenser des dizaines de milliers
d'enfants comme ashley arrachés à leurs
familles est souvent à leur communauté
ottawa débloqué une enveloppe de 20
milliards de dollars un montant sans
précédent
l'argent qui sera versée à chaque
victime reste encore à déterminer mais
ottawa s'engage à ce qu'il soit d'au
moins 40 milles dollars par enfant une
petite somme quand on pense à l'ampleur
des traumatismes croit cet avocat est
ravi de sa famille sa communauté
événement majeur dans la vie des enfants
le gouvernement fédéral va dépenser un
autre 20 milliards pour réformer le
système de protection à l'enfance et
surtout financer des initiatives qui
pourraient aider les parents autochtone
à garder leurs enfants à la maison par
exemple des programmes de lutte contre
les dépendances ou pour subvenir à des
besoins essentiels comme le chauffage et
la nourriture la partie la plus
importante sans doute c'est vraiment de
s'assurer qu'il y aura une implication
des premières nations dans la démarche
on essaie de l'assemblée des premières
nations du québec l'entente de principe
et historique même si elle ne pourra pas
réparer tous les torts subis on vient de
mettre un terme finalement un processus
au sein de nos communautés qui s'étend
sur au moins trop eu trois décennies
plus et je pense qu'on vient apporter
très certainement au niveau de cette
sanction je dirais le coureur
principalement les familles qui ont été
directement contacté les différents
groupes autochtones et le gouvernement
fédéral espère qu'au delà de cette
entente de principe un accord final
approuvé par les tribunaux seront
conclues au cours des prochains mois
pour le gouvernement trudeau ce serait
l'occasion de prouver qu'au-delà de sa
promesse d'une réconciliation
il peut aussi contribuer à des
changements concrets et si laurence arte
radio canada ottawa